have you ever sent or received a nude
photograph
yes and
yes
go on then how do you feel about that
dad
i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised at all
[Music]
how much do you know about your daughter
how much are you worried about revealing
to you today i know that if i look at
this pile of questions that i don't know
the answers to probably all of them uh
but i suspect the answers to all of them
and so uh we we've always let you plough
your own thorough haven't we and that's
in that side
trouble is you've plowed too many photos
how many people have you slept with do i
need the calculator
potentially
oh
[Laughter]
i don't think we should get into that
conversation right now okay
i'm happy to be the pastor there's been
a few can you remember everybody you
slept with
we don't have time for this
sorry i've just made that question i've
just made that question up have a pen
i'll just write that down
i don't think you'd want to know
what's your favorite sex position
wow okay um
doggy style doggy style
that's it
have your finger just locked up there
dying okay next question please i
actually don't want to know the answer
to this one have you ever heard me have
sex
once only once when i was
i think 10 we just moved into the new
house did it sound like i was enjoying
yourself no shut up
definitely not i was just like ah i
shouldn't be here and then ran away i
didn't know that there you go well
thankfully it's not something i'd bring
up at the breakfast dave on yeah i heard
you both at it oh actually yeah
have you ever stolen anything from me
yes what i used to take your american
dollars and go swap them at the post
office for english money
did you really yeah so when i came back
from brewery they were hidden in your
briefcase in your wardrobe and i found
them one day and that was my little
stash for a while i did it quite
regularly
sorry if you had the opportunity to
switch genders for a day right yeah
what's the first thing you would do okay
so me and my mates actually talk about
this quite a lot you talk about me yeah
we do me and steph especially and we
always say that we'd want to dip our
bollocks and hummus
just like grab them and drop them in
there
i've no idea why and then obviously you
know how difficult that would be i know
it's quite niche isn't it yeah and then
also i don't know i just want to like
put it in stuff
like just anything no doughnuts now you
know what a man feels like that yeah
well you've got one of those you just
want to put it in put it in i've never
put my bollocks in humorous
or in a joke
this is humorous
[Laughter]
have you ever sent or received a nude
photograph
yes and
yes
go on then how do you feel about that
dad i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised at all i mean it's
just life nowadays isn't it nudes yeah
yeah
yeah yeah nudes i mean uh nudes so
you've got not you
when was the last time you had sex
well dad um it's been a bit of a drought
thanks to their pandemic
so you mean i'm winning so far steve won
emily
when your parents have got a better sex
life than you it's actually quite tragic
uh but yes you are winning it's been a
while
[Laughter]
what age did you start watching porn
like regularly
i reckon like 20 days was it when you
did you see your foot you want to know
more i don't know what did you see your
first really on on the internet then
did i say my first bully on the internet
yeah well it would have been on the
telly i reckon
um what was it euro trash oh yeah
remember that i remember europe and i
used to watch it on mute in my bedroom
just in case it really worked just in
case you came in and then i could hear
the footsteps and i could turn it off
quickly so yeah euro trash is where i
saw my first willy all right for on a
follow up with that one what's your most
watched porn
genre
you don't have to press it twice i'm
still actually suffering from the first
one
there you go right okay
that means there is one though that's
the end there is an answer yes but you
can have you can have the facts but you
don't need to know the details
do you think that i've been a good
parent yes dad you have been an amazing
parent i don't like being too cheesy and
gushing do i but yes i think you've been
an amazing parent and done everything
within your power to try and make me and
jack happy and you're an absolute
character everyone loves you thank you
dawn you're welcome
i don't oh yeah that was cute wasn't it
yeah i enjoyed that quite funny
what's your favorite sex position
i'm not i'm not answering that i am not
answering that oh
yeah and i didn't want to know you can't
be just man on top women need more
shut up mother look at my finger